you probably already guessed that a  watchdog sequel was in the works well it  is and Ubisoft confirmed that we'll get  our hands on it by the end of the next  fiscal year in other words watchdogs to  will launch by April 2017 in April 2015  a senior gameplay programmer at Ubisoft  listed the sequel on his resume and the  rumors started flying since then we've  heard plenty from watchdogs creative  executive Johnathan Morin who says the  sequel has to take some big risks we'll  see those risks in action next year  watchdogs to isn't the only big game on  Ubisoft's plate for honor Ghost Recon  wildlands and southpark the fractured  butthole are all set to launch by April  2017 they've also teased a brand new  triple a title that isn't tied to any  existing franchise don't worry we're  keeping up with all of those games at  gamespot  you